[Musik]
halo hat ist willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es von uns ein kleines
halloween special und zwar werde ich
euch in diesem video
drei tolle ideen zeigen die ihr auch mit
kindern zubereiten können und zwar für
euer gruseliges halloween befehl heute
gibt zum einen gruselige eier mit
spinnen drauf es gibt gruselige mumien
aus dem backofen und es gibt
blutunterlaufene augen
das ganze klingt ziemlich eklig aber es
schmeckt natürlich alles super lecker
das sind drei herrschaften rezepte de
wirklich super einfach zubereiten könnt
und auch gar nicht viele zutaten
benötigt ich starte jetzt sofort mit der
ersten idee das sind nämlich die eier
gewinnen und dafür zeige ich euch mal
was ihr dafür vorbereiten müsse für die
größe leider habe ich schon mal sechs
eier hartgekocht und habe sie mit kaltem
wasser abgeschreckt jetzt habe ich hier
noch mal wasser im topf und gebt
lebensmittel verpasste rein da könnte
jetzt die farbe eurer wahl nehmen ich
nehme jetzt einfach schwarz braucht man
auch gar nicht viel
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch mit
blaubär saft oder mutter beete saft oder
auch anderen fruchtsäften färben die
ebene starke farbe haben
jetzt ist es ganz schön schwarz jetzt
nehme ich die eier und klopfte einfach
so ein bisschen auf die arbeitsfläche
aber die schale wird jetzt nicht
entfernt sondern einfach nur angebrochen
damit die farbe durch die schale
durchdringen kann das sind große
geräusche und dann lege ich die eier
einfach wieder ein vater
[Musik]
jetzt weiß ich die eier so einfach vier
stunden ziehen damit sie die farbe
annehmen können die eier sind jetzt
schon durchgezogen ich habe das war's
jetzt auch schon weg gegossen und jetzt
kommt natürlich die füllung ihr kennt
vielleicht das rezept auch als russische
eier das heißt ihr könnt jetzt mit dem
eigelb sozusagen eine creme der paste
machen und die wirklich auch nach
geschmack abwandeln ich zeige euch jetzt
mal meine version für die eier brauche
ich einen halben teelöffel was habe zwei
teelöffel senf 100 gramm frischkäse im
doppel ram stufe ein paar oliven salz
und pfeffer werde ich zuerst einmal die
eierschale papas tipp einmal in der hand
rollen wo er irgendwie sehen die kaputt
aus aber irgendwie auch gruselig murats
tipps zu drei wochen stehen dann sehen
sie auch so
ganz ohne farbe
[Musik]
jetzt handelt die einer längs halbieren
und dann das gelbe herausnehmen und das
gebe ich dann einfach mit zum frischkäse
dazu
[Musik]
das erkennt jetzt mit dem frischkäse ein
bisschen zerdrücken und ihr könnt ihr
zum beispiel auch schmand oder joghurt
oder saurer sahne nehmen
da kommt jetzt noch senf mir dazu und
auch der wasabi und ich hab hier den
süßen senf also in feigensenf gewählt
vom selbstgemachten von der ingrid den
bekommen wir hier immer aus der region
und da kann ich das ganze noch mit salz
und pfeffer würzen und die paste muss
jetzt einfach ganz ganz schön
geschmeidig gerührt werden und so ein
bisschen verstrichen werden damit ich es
gleich auch durch einen spritzbeutel
durchbekommen
[Musik]
die masse habe ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer stern schüler
gefüllt ihr könnt aber auch einen
gefrierbeutel nehmen oder das ganze auch
mit einem löffel drauf spritzen
sagen wir einfach eine richtig schöne
form so können die 1 gefüllt werden und
ich habe jetzt ein paar einfach mal
umgedreht damit ihr das schöne muster
erkennen könnt
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr das ganze nochmal
verschönern mit spinnen ich bin ja
eigentlich nicht zum spinnen liebhaber
aber egal ich hab jetzt hier ne halbe
olive und habe ich eben noch in kleine
dünne füße geschnitten und die können
jetzt hier drauf setzen
ich bin kein spieler und fan und keinen
liebhaber aber ich glaube spiele vom 8
[Musik]
jetzt sind die eier fertig die stelle
ich jetzt so lange in den kühlschrank
und werde euch jetzt zeigen wie man
gruselige mumien herstellt für den
hefeteig brauche ich 250 gramm mehl
einen esslöffel trockenhefe 130
milliliter warmes wasser einen halben
teelöffel salz und zucker und drei
esslöffel olivenöl
ich nehme jetzt das mehl und weil es
sind halt einfach mal mit der hand
verkneten es geht auch super schnell in
die mitte kommt eine munde
da gebe ich jetzt die hefe mit reinen
ihr könnt auch frische hebe benutzen
aber trockenhefe hat man eben auch immer
auflage dann ein wenig wasser und
verrührt wir kommen jetzt noch salz und
pfeffer mit rein und dann kann ich mit
dem restlichen wasser einfach den
kompletten hefeteig verrühren
[Musik]
zum schluss kommt jetzt noch das öl mit
dazu und dann kneten teig einfach für
etwa zwei bis drei minuten
das faultier den teig zu einer kugel und
dann gebe ich ihnen in einer schüssel
decken ab und lass ihn für etwa eine
halbe stunde stunde aufgeben der teig
ist jetzt gut aufgegangen und den kann
ich jetzt einfach ganz dünn ausrollen
und jetzt könnt ihr den teig in streifen
schneiden entweder mit einem messer oder
mit einem pizza rat nicht nehmen ist das
witzig weil es fünf klingen gleichzeitig
hat und ich einfach somit schneller
arbeiten kann
jetzt nehme ich immer einen teig
streifen und hier habe ich bereits
würstchen das sind muras lieblings
würstchen vom türken holt er die immer
und die kann ich jetzt so ein bisschen
damit einwickeln und zwar so dass oben
ein bisschen beim gesicht so zu sagen
was frei bleibt da gucken nämlich später
noch die augen raus und der rest wird
einfach so drumherum gewickelt muss auch
gar nicht so sorgfältig sein denn mumien
sie nicht immer sorgfältig eingewickelt
und die kann ich dann hier auf ein blech
legen und so kommen jetzt die arme
würstchen die mumien in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa zwölf bis 15 minuten
ich schaue einfach und nehmen sie dann
heraus wenn sie schön goldbraun sind ja
aber wirst du so sehen die mumie netz
aus nach dem backen ihr könnt jetzt
gerne schon zu lassen oder noch mit
augen verzieren
ich habe es hier einmal eine version mit
gelben augen gesehen ziemlich gruselig
aus könnt ihr zum beispiel aus senf
machen oder auch aus zucker schrift so
geschrieben ist zwar süß aber ich finde
das passt trotzdem oder ihr könnt eine
comic variante machen mit diesen zucker
augen
die habe ich einfach mit bisschen von
der zeitschrift angeklebt aber da könnte
auch ein dutzend senf oder so drunter
machen
ich mache es einfach beide versionen
weil ich beide sehr lustig finde
[Musik]
die mumien sind jetzt fertig jetzt kommt
unsere dritte idee und zwar sind es die
gruseligen augen
dafür brauchen wir wirklich nur ganz
wenige zutaten sie haben wir ein paar
babybel also käse welchen wir haben ein
paar oliven ringe und einfach
lebensmittel passte und etwas ketchup
hier nehmen wir jetzt die bbl und margit
mit der lebensmittel verpasste mit einem
pinsel ganz kleine dünne äderchen drauf
ja wieso blutunterlaufene augen unter
beispiel ein als sommer
[Musik]
mama darf ich jetzt mal ja wahnsinnig
schöner und ich nehme so lange die
oliven ringe die kommen nämlich hier
drauf und die mitte fühle ich dann noch
mit etwas ketchup fertig ist dann auch
die dritte idee und jetzt zeigen wir
euch gleich mal unsere buffet
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt fertig und murat steht
schon in den startlöchern zum probieren
sein er möchte so eine mumie probieren
oder kann ich noch nie probiert
du darfst die haben kommen du kriegst
große leege samira kriegt die hier und
hier haben wir noch die übersicht gelbe
sind man kann es nicht selbst machen
damit zucker schrift einfach genommen
aber schon nicht schlimm mannschaft
jetzt ja ok wir hatten keinen ja wir
hatten hat keinen löwensenf beschließen
deswegen haben wir hier auch ein bisserl
den süßen senf reihen aber der mittel
schaaf ist es natürlich besser probieren
und schmeckt mein schatz die sind immer
gut geld kann schon macht die augen
probier s mal gut bei den augen gibt es
nicht viel zu probieren also bb schmeckt
immer gut aber es hat eine coole
gruselige idee das eis um gefahren so
much more tears and bayer probieren das
sieht aus aber festgestellt wie so ein
bisschen gehirn passt ja ich habe den
feigen sind drin aber man müsste
eigentlich mit den scharfen senf nehmen
wird mir besser schmecken und was haben
wir drin
nicht nur das geht nicht mehr sagt
machen wir gehen gleich die badewanne
ja ich mache dir das ist aber schon
texte über politik natal also müssen
jetzt alle hinter gebrachte wanne
ich finde das waren richtig coole drei
rezeptideen für eure nächste halloween
party falls ihr sie nach macht man
schickt uns gerne ein foto auf facebook
oder instagram markiert uns und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß nachmachen
geburtstag
bis zum nächsten mal ich habe jetzt
schon ganz gut
[Musik]
gleich werden ein arroganter trägt auch
noch sagen oh guck mal
wo kann ich nicht weg ich kein blut
sketch nur farbe bin jetzt eigentlich wo
wir sind
[Musik]